guys we just saw the best Marvel movie
ever ever I know it can seem like we say
that every time we walk out of a Marvel
movie cuz we do but it's true
this is the best Marvel movie ever and
Disney only paid us $50 to say that ever
the both of us the both of us $25 each
five went to parking but it was worth it
I go I go only got 20 well
you're white we saw Ant Man in the lost
people guy in the wisp I'm sure you guys
already got a bunch of reviews 9:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time 12:00 p.m. Eastern
Time didn't Jim we're late to the game
cuz I wanted to digest this movie let's
go into it as I'm sure you've heard a
lot of people say this we're doing
exploiters don't spoil anything for you
well do the spoiler review later we're
all gonna spoil anything I'm just going
to tell you guys the the ending right
away the post-credits ruin your life
panel shows up it just steps on Scotland
it's a really sad well the reason why I
wouldn't want to do anything spoiler at
all is because of the fact that the
trailers don't actually reveal the main
plot maybe there's like a TV spot or
something that hints at it the main plot
of the movie is not touched on in the
official trailers for this film so I
don't feel right going into it what I
can tell you guys is this what do you
expect when you watch the trailer for
this movie you're expecting a film that
is going to be funny and perhaps funnier
than the first ant-man and has better
action sequences and the Fagor yes yes
that is a big key word here is clever
this film is very clever
and the fact that Peyton Reed was kind
of brought in a little last minute for
the first ant-man and is now doing this
with a lot more prep time you're
expecting a better directed film and
this film delivers on all three of those
elements it's very funny it's funnier
than the first got to give it that yeah
it's very clever the action is much
better and the direction overall is just
a much more confident direction yeah I
feel like this film overall just finds
the perfect blend of his tones for the
most part and uses all of its pieces to
the utmost degree words like in the
first one there are things that could
have been a little smoother and whatnot
this one has a lot more style very world
I'd liked it a lot I liked it a hell of
a lot I don't love this film I don't
want that it communicators if I have
even have issues with the movie because
whatever criticisms I go into with the
film it's not like they're flawed it's
just there's some stuff that has limited
emotional effect when I feel they want
it to have more impact if that makes
sense it's really just the way my
emotions responded to something like
stakes certain characters in the movie
but what you primarily show up for is
great that's the thing though you
primarily show up for is really good
it's like there are a couple minor
complaints I would have like certain
transitions feel a bit quick or certain
things you wish got maybe a little bit
more fleshed out but other than that
like just the idea of everything that's
going on the main course of action and
the use of pretty much all the
characters really satisfied me true I
rewatched the first ant-man
a couple days ago and I'm glad I did
what I found fascinating about this
movie is yes there are sequels in the
MCU there is an Iron Man 2 there is a
Thor the dark world there's a Captain
America Winter Soldier there's an
argument to be made for Iron Man 2 but
usually the sequels don't feel as direct
of a sequel yeah to the prior one this
one is essentially continuing the same
story that happened in the first ant-man
and some Civil War context mixed in yeah
yeah yeah definitely but even that they
do a good job of recapping past they did
a good job of recapping that in a way
where you if you didn't see Civil War
you'll be fine they're really treated
this
a sense of what are the elements that we
teased at the end of the first ant-man
and how can we continue this same story
where is the most natural progression I
appreciated that a lot actually
especially coming after infinity war
because this movie has a lot of same
weight oh yeah
really dark yeah it's got a lot of
levity but also I like the way it's
world feels a bit more contained it's
like having it directly connect to the
first ant man makes the ant-man movies
kind of feel like their own little
bubble yeah and not so much like the
whole entire universe you know which is
a nice change of pace yeah it is a nice
change of pace especially because not
just infinity war I mean Black Panther
was like and here there's major stakes
for their very personal yeah their major
stakes for the characters so they're
very personal stakes I think the issue
that I tend to find when I look back on
it is by the time you get to the finale
there are so many plot lines going on a
lot happening and they all have their
own sense of stakes they all make for
fun adventures and they make for fun
action sequences and some very clever
sequences but there's emotional effect
where I'm like I'm not really feeling
the stakes because there's so much going
on yeah you kind of wish that certain
people especially a certain of the more
antagonist etype characters maybe got a
little more flesh for their stories so
that we could care completely or even
trimmed there's one storyline that I
felt was not necessary made for cool
sequences but I didn't find it a hundred
percent necessary the what I wish I was
ant-man right now so I could like zip
over there on top of that dog's mouth
the walton goggins storyline actually
provided some of the best action moments
in this film totally but when I look
back on it it kind of contributes to the
feeling of there's a lot going on and if
they cut him out and put some of those
plot elements with the other characters
yeah this could have been more even more
personal and more effective with that
being said Walton Goggins delivers a
good performance wasp the best part of
this movie wasp
waswas awesome weirder picks up what
hope Van Dyne in this film is a
supernatural progression not
supernatural but but a natural
progression from where the first hand
man left off with her character
specifically I'm glad she's got longer
hair because I hate her hair in the
first one she looks so much better here
she kicked some serious ass and I even
liked their chemistry between Paul Rudd
and her even more in this film there's
some really surprising sequences like
there's a surprise scene where her and
hand man are doing it and then as
they're doing it they get covered in
ants yeah and they're just making love
with and like post-credits thing I
actually hint that they're gonna have
like a hybrid ant human baby yeah you
know because the quantum radiation
that's not similar to Ant Man one where
the real heart of the movie is not with
its lead Scott laying it's not the story
of hank pym man yeah yeah and this film
is specially though it starts off in a
way where okay this is another Scott
Lang tale and it had his woman his is
one of his stories it's an adventure he
is along for by the time you're like
halfway through this movie you're like
oh this is really a hope and dinin story
yeah he starts to feel like a real
supporting character when he is the
title character it's like yes it says
and the wasp in it yeah but even more so
in this movie than the last one he feels
a lot more like a supporting character
he's good though he's funnier in this
movie is a comedy overall I thought
worked a lot better and jived with the
overall T yeah a lot more in this movie
like I like the comedy in the first one
but there are a lot of moments where it
felt like they just inserted a joke and
especially like the banter like the
first movie the situational comedy
always worked but in this one the banter
also banter is great in it and the ghost
character the villain tease and the
trailers I'm very mixed on I love the
concept of her and I love the ideas and
the effects of her yeah cool awesome
phasing effects that you've seen the
trailer are really cool it's just they
had these plot elements to her that are
supposed to make her feel a lot more
layered but the execution on the writing
doesn't give her much to do with the
performance so you kind of get a OneNote
performance when what they talk about
the information
give on her allows for a more layered
character something along the lines of a
kill monger it's a good idea it's a good
story point but yeah you don't really
get to spend a lot of time in Hershey
you don't get sick like dint feel it her
but the movie wants you to feel it I
could tell the movie wants you to yeah
and I thought of Hannah John came in
like did a good job like I liked what
she brought but again I'm totally with
you it's like I feel like if she just
had a little bit more variety in the
types of moments they let her play that
might have helped this movie but that
being said the overall idea of what they
did with that character I was actually
surprised by and actually really like I
could see that being something that
might improve in the future for this one
especially towards like the last half
hour she started to feel kind of
annoying in terms of what she was there
for in the plot you put it the best when
you said it feels like she's getting the
way for most yeah yeah she's not the
main focus of the film she's one of
several but the main focus she feel like
you're interfering with the main party I
know that's the point of hers the threat
it has a limited effect you also get a
cool performance from Laurence Fishburne
in here who plays a character who was
once Goliath in the comic books yeah
21 feet tall I don't want to give away
what they do with this character in this
movie was more than just Laurence
Fishburne's here for a scene you know
he's an actual character in this movie
yeah I mean it was nice to have him here
a surprise role that I wasn't expecting
to be used so much was a new addition of
Randall Park yeah that's like an FBI he
this is Randall Park thing yeah so funny
it's hilarious in it and Michael Pena is
hilarious so as usual even the team the
supporting players ti-ti and David dust
Malkin who gets a particularly funny
Gaghan yeah like I remember thinking
though like Michael Pena was funny but
the other two weren't that funny yeah
they're all funny yeah they're all funny
in this one yeah they all get a chance
to shine in this movie the main cast in
the supporting cast both I thought
really all got moments like Scott's
family like Judy Greer and Bobby kind of
all I only show up like once or twice
but yeah they're even leaving
impressions when they get there yeah
yeah and Michael Douglas is really cool
in the film too do we like him now there
was that whole thing we thought he was
sick so maybe that sort of blunted the
I'm like what's we cool them anyway I
don't really know the details of his
first little life or that old salt story
I do think that he does a great job in
the film and I wasn't watching it
thinking about it to me he was the best
performer of the last one and he carries
that same level of commitment and
strength in this film as well so yeah I
think the cast is really good it's funny
in the first one it's better action and
it has a better grip on just its
imagination like really making use of
the ant-man and the wasp shrinking and
growing up and and yeah quantum realm
elements and even though the trailers
teased almost every scene in this movie
everybody but there's still a lot of big
surprises in terms of clever sequences
and really clever bits well if I run the
spoiler everything there's some really
truly like wow it's a great effects -
they say yeah yeah yeah totally
I like it a lot and I keep a lookout for
us for the review I would give it like a
solid 3.75 out of 550 yeah yeah there
are things that could be better but just
as an enjoyable installment of this
franchise it improves upon the first
it's a blasts of fun events like yeah
yeah and it's it's a nice scope to give
some variety to the MCU right now hey
what would you do if you could shrink
down to ant size you know would you what
did you do ant stuff would you do
something perverted probably I guess
that's probably what people would do but
but leave your feedback and I'm sorry
the real rejects click that notification
bell and check us on patreon Foley TV
show reactions we've become a big data
[Music]